[Music]  making a very revenge where's Robert  where's your husband  it tears and the soul where's your  brother now but it can also be a weapon  I'm done with running and I'm sick of  hating how it's making decisions and  whatever course you are charting I  choose you my husband  we need in unite Scotland Robert the  Bruce is enough for any man or woman who  would give shelter to him or his ranks  is to be executed without trial the  people are desperate for justice  I serve Robert Bruce join us  [Applause]  how fifty men to fight the strongest  this is how we did it  take the Lombok castle by castle  goodbye for god  [Music]  for culturing  funnily  I do not care  so long as you  you